encore des nouvelles révélations sur la
sphère johnny hallyday on vous à yako
des rebondissements donc là je me suis
dit si je commence à résumer on a fini à
23h45
donc j'ai préparons nous à préparer à la
rédaction un petit résumé en images
c'est une nouvelle qui ajoute encore un
peu plus d'eau au moulin de la polémique
autour des rumeurs sur johnny alors que
laetitia avait fait savoir que les
relations entre david hallyday son père
n'était pas au beau fixe de nouvelles
indiscrétions tendrait à prouver le
contraire
dans un documentaire diffusé sur nrj 12
sur l'héritage de johnny une information
surprenante et révélé johnny et son fils
échangé des sms régulièrement et j'avais
mis au point un code c'est issa ne
connaissais pas johnny avait dit à david
quand je te répondrais moi je
commencerai mais à sames par fiston une
révélation très surprenante qui laisse
entendre que le rockeur se méfier de son
entourage mais de qui avaient ils peur
qu'ils pouvaient envoyer des messages à
sa place une question qui reste
aujourd'hui sans réponse mais qui
relance une fois encore les suspicions
sur les manipulations autour de
l'héritage
alors deux d'abord je voudrais dire
bonjour à roland perez bonjour pendant
allait bien
si le cache pas que vous êtes toujours
très élégant tiré à quatre épingles mais
alors là c'est bleu marine et ce noir
est choisit le magnifique chine et tout
le monde ce soir en fait l'achat rivasi
ma fille moi excusez moi oui c'est vrai
qu'on doit alors je laisse mon père soit
là on me met dans chine et d'autre alors
avant de faire des jaloux
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aime bien remplacer série là de
simples lieux tasse et cyril parce que
c'est moi et embrasse les invités temps
des séries bon alors demain soir ya un
lien documentaire exclusif sur nrj12 qui
s'appelle héritage spéciale johnny
hallyday qui nous apprend des trucs
absolument incroyable et notamment son
revenu sur les rapports entre david
hallyday et son père et là on découvre
que le papa et le fiston aurait établi
une sorte de code secret pour pouvoir
communiquer regardez c'est assez dingue
il y avait-il une vraie envie de
réconciliation où était ce un simple
coup de com et j'avais mis au point un
code c'est issa ne connaissais pas
johnny avait dit à david quand je te
répondrais moi je commencerai mes sms
par fiston découvrez comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu la bataille médiatique
et judiciaire pour l'héritage de johnny
hallyday bon alors là ça devient mais
sait on est on est au delà de dallas et
dallas dynastie je ne sais quoi d'autre
encore mélangé là dedans
donc il semblerait si on en croit ce
documentaire avec ses révélations
exclusives que lorsque johnny voulait
écrire à son fils et pour prouver que
c'était bien lui qui écrivait il devait
démarrer le sms par fiston a confié
parcours qui aurait pu prendre le
téléphone et que écrire à la place de
johnny qu'est ce que cela sous-entend
tout ça alors je confirme je confirme
beaucoup fait clairement que c'est vrai
c'était un code vous écris un
documentaire s'est renchéri de notre
chaîne pour venir le dirigeant
non ça c'est un scoop je crois que
jamais l'info mais en fait j'ai attendu
que donne alors je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord c'est par respect pour
tout le monde je n'ai pas au nom par la
saisie est pas un peu ça me laisse ce
genre de détails très intimes très privé
il se trouve que notre ami david
hallyday n'a pas pu n'a pas voulu en
parler lors du 7 à 8 et en fait c'est
catherine rambert qui l'a révélé
découflé c'est pas une rumeur non non
non c'est vrai c'est un code entre
johnny et son défenseur donc pourquoi
j'avais raison parce que j'ai déjà
évoqué dans cette émission il se trouve
que laetitia avait une fâcheuse manie
d'où la brouille à l'époque avec
alessandra serait-il fâcheuse manie
parce que ben oui aurait si vous voulez
alors il fait chaud samedi de fâcheuse
manie c'est de regarder les téléphones
des autres par exemple si vous êtes à
côté ça sonne et belle regarder des
machins et comme alpiq est souvent le
téléphone johnny qui n'était pas mais
qui se baladait avec le téléphone johnny
jean téléphonie l'opposé d'un porto ils
sont quelques uns auraient pu pardon ni
clous ou soir à recevoir un texto de de
laura ou de david elle efface et
pourquoi pas mais vous estimez que les
relations étaient telles qu'elles
auraient pu effacer avant dé vue depuis
ce qui s'est passé à l'hôpital du cedars
sinaï à los angeles lorsqu'il avait été
c'est malheureusement baisse a commencé
là des génériques ce qui me désole un
peu c'est qu'on diabolise en fait
laetitia juste avec des on dit parce que
dans mercy en fait dans tout ça
je suis désolé on entend les gens parler
maintenant les gens ouvrir maintenant
donner leur dossier maintenant quand il
était là johnny personnes par les
personnes ne disaient ni l'état ni
personne et maintenant tout le monde
crie une une aubaine ou et ensuite je
sais une chose que se serrer les parents
autour de la table donc là moi je me
pose la question en tant que maman papa
maman papa
cette histoire de devoir d'y envoyer
peut-être un sms à son fils en disant je
te certifie mais par code secret que
c'est bien moi qui tu écris c'est assez
désastreux elle va vous étiez fan de
johnny on voit bien sûr voie jeudi à une
heure qu'est ce qu'on a dépensé toutes
ces révélations qui arrive jour après
jour et alors honnêtement ça je peux pas
prendre parti puisque je pense qu'à
partir du moment où on vit pas avec
les gens ont peut pas avoir de fin on
sait pas on sait même pas ce qui se
passe réellement
maintenant c'est vrai que si jamais ça
c'était vrai là par contre je trouverais
ça terrible parce que de là à se cacher
pour écrire effectivement à son enfant
je trouve ça quand même grave mais il ya
quand même là il ya quand même des
éléments qui ne qui ne trompent pas
roland à vous rappelez vous que vous
êtes plutôt du côté du camp oui alors
jade hugh laurie
oui j'essaie d'être quand même
relativement objectif il ya quand même
des choses qui ne trompent pas on sait
par exemple que johnny ne chantait plus
l'aura sur scène on sait qu'il ne
chantait plus 100% la fille de la
chanson de son fils dont conseil qu'il y
avait une espèce de demain mise ainsi
parce qu'il parce que y avait pas ce que
vous en temps vous sous-entendez qu'il y
avait une sorte de record de la mort de
laëtitia quoi chanter tout un succès et
pas chanter des chansons aussi
symbolique que la chanson qu'il avait
dédié à sachiez que vous opposez et je
peux vous opposez qu'il avait un
répertoire tellement vaste qu'il fallait
faire un choix oui mais ça a été
drastique c'est à dire qu'elle à partir
d'une certaine période il ne les a plus
chanter je pense que laura s'est exprimé
aussi elle disait qu'elle ne pouvait
avoir des rendez vous avec son père que
qu'en cachette
donc elle n'a effectivement aussi
exprimer catherine rambert qui a fait ce
livre et qui l'être dans ce formidable
demain reportage dessus d'héritage sur
nrj12 7,2 d'ambert je suis dedans ne me
prêtez pas je ne suis pas sur le plateau
j'ai donné une interview mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que catherine rambert
qui va qui va sortir d'ailleurs un livre
a vraiment interviewé elle et c'est une
journaliste de terrain elle a interviewé
les proches et ses les proches qui lui
ont révélé la même pas d'avis qu'il a
fait david a gardé cette pudeur de ne
rien révéler de ne rien dire et même si
là s'il a exprimé sa peine
vraiment on véritable dans sept à huit
on a vu cette pudeur et cette discrétion
roland pas lui rolland qui est une
question parce que à l'audience on est
on est revenu à l'audience qui s'est
tenue la en début de semaine on est
revenu les avocats sont revenus sur une
citation de laeticia hallyday ce qu'on
va parler un peu de l'héritage
maintenant sur une citation de laeticia
hallyday dans le point qui au moment du
décès de johnny avait dit j'ai épousé la
france la tour eiffel chaque français a
un lien avec lui à travers une chanson à
souvenirs
et je sais que lors de l'audience les
avocats ont utilisé cette phrase pour
dire vous voyez c'est le testament
français qui doit prendre le pas puisque
laetitia sa veuve elle même dit johnny
c'est pasl'amérique johnny c'est la
france c'est exact oui alors c'est vrai
que les avocats se sont empressés d'en
et se sont engouffrées dans ces noms
parce que je pense que les juges vont
vraiment rester sur le droit sur la
directive européenne qui doit être
appliqué sur ce sur ce comptage tout
simplement des jours et des mois qui ont
précédé le décès pour savoir si johnny
véritablement intéressé plus de six mois
et un jour en france ou six 6 mois et un
jour plus tôt aux états unis pour
établir sa résidence qui va être
vraiment la résidence est aujourd'hui en
droit français est le critère la
résidence permanente en france aux états
unis et le critère qui va déterminer
l'application de la loi alors donc ils
vont alors après tout un ensemble
là vous avez raison c'est qu'ils
écoutent tout ce qu'il y à un ensemble
de choses des revenus en france une
carrière en france et ce que je vous
coupe mais est ce que le trust on a dit
que maintenant les américains abandonné
la gestion de ce trust est ce que ça
c'est un point positif pour david et
laura est ce que ça veut ça voudrait
dire que du coup il ya tellement de
soucis que les américains disent
finalement je m'en lave les mains ça va
rester du domaine des français c'est un
casse tête je peux vous dire que les
magistrats ont été face à un casse tête
ils se sont retirés pour délibérer pour
savoir s'il est ou non renvoyé cette
affaire ils ont été très bons mais ils
n'ont pas cité totale quand même est ce
que on a beau se battre peut-être qu'à
la fin il restera rien parce que tout
est rentré dans des trusts et troc de
maisons des trusts financiers maintenant
des trusts de droits artistiques donc
une opacité et les avocats des deux
aînés ont beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés pour obtenir des éléments
donc le tribunal quand on a annoncé que
la bank of america qui était assigné en
référé l'avocat est venu dire voilà la
lettre de démission on vous donnera pas
les raisons j'ai pas de raison à vous
donner
mais il ya plus le représentant ils se
les bras m'en sont tombés parce que ils
se sont dit qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
une des parties qui devra exécuter la
décision qu'on a rendu qu'il devrait
être opposable 6g personne à qui rendre
opposables cette décision c'est embêtant
donc ils se sont retirés ils sont
revenus et ils ont finalement pris je
pense l'importance des demandes qui ont
été faites et ils ont décidé quand même
de statuer c'est ce qu'on saura dans
quelques jours dans quelques
maintenant moi c'est ça exactement sur
la fortune de laëtitia parce que
certains journalistes se sont penchés
sur sa fortune en disant que finalement
c'était pas si clair que ça et notamment
léna lutaud qui est une journaliste bien
connu qui est dit ce qui m'a alerté
c'est l'avocat de laetitia qui répétait
dans toutes les interviews qu'elle était
asphyxié moi je la voyais sur instagram
aller dans les restaurants etc
du coup j'ai mené ma petite enquête et
je me suis rendu compte que finalement
il l avait beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
est ce que c'est le cas a pas le cas du
tout une journaliste détective
absolument incroyable elle s'est rendue
un peu partout et elle a surtout fait
des recoupements sur les réseaux sociaux
de fans qui parlait de villa qui n'était
pas finalement dans leurs dents dans les
villes l'a décrite qu'elle connaissait
notamment aux à los angeles sa ville
appartiennent à laetitia jaujou à sa
désapprobation comprends d'après ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'elle appartient en
partie à l'elysée avec johnny et l'autre
partie sera jean claude darmon au sein
d'une société qui aurait fait également
l'objet d'un autre trust et ne lui
appartiennent pas à 100% on ne peut pas
partir en partie à johnny donc en partie
elle choisit donc ça devrait rentrer
dans l'héritage à rendre dans l'héritage
non c'est surtout la maison de saint
marc est à moitié avec darmon mediaset
de los angeles qui est à 100% pour elle
ou la suite du décès de john alors ce
qu'on a découvert cette nouvelle maison
de malibu qu'elle loue et dont elle
touche et loyers toujours actuellement
et tant mieux pour elle mais en tout cas
ça ça appartient à 100% à laëtitia je
parle pas de la maison où elle vit à
pacific palissades salle est une autre
d'accord qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous est-ce que tout de même on va aller
vers parce que j'ai entendu quelques
avocats dire finalement c'est une
technique d'avocats de sa boyer un peu
dessus de sortir des dossiers à droite à
gauche est en fait tout ça c'est sûr
deux sont des sortes de contre ce parce
qu'en fait en sous main en parallèle on
essaie de négocier aussi est ce que
c'est ce qui va peut se produire lors
même qu'ils aimeraient qu'on aimera miss
réconcilier on attend alors une famille
qui se réconcilient bien sûr mais une
famille recomposée qui serait consigne
c'est toujours toujours un peu compliqué
mais il s'avère que les parties ne se
parle pas directement
c'est à dire que je pense que laeticia
et david et lætitia et lowrie tous les
trois ne se sont pas parlé depuis
l'ouverture des tubes de testament
prédit-il ne se sont jamais plus parler
donc aujourd'hui ce sont les avocats
mais les avocats
pardonnez-moi excuse
les avocats aussi pourrait dire mettons
nous autour d'une table chargée vivement
voyez-vous des messages peut-être même
par sms dit non non surtout ne faites
pas d'erreur vous avez raison mais pour
ça il faudrait qu'il y à minima une
transparence une quant aux parents 7 sur
les éléments c'est à dire que si on
vient en disant voilà ce qu'on a
voilà ce qu'on a fait voilà ce que
souhaitait johnny c'est possible on peut
l'entendre aussi et voilà ce qu'il
faudrait pour est pour protéger les deux
titres les deux dernières séances à 100
ans
mais le problème c'est que à la fois il
n'y a pas de transparence
et puis à la fois on s'aperçoit que de
l'autre côté du côté laetitia il ya des
choses qui sont faites aux états unis
qui vont encore un peu plus et opacifier
compliqué ce qui devrait être
éventuellement dénouer je sais que ça
passionne tout le monde mais moi je suis
sidéré de voir tout ce qui sort en fait
il ya un truc dont on parle jamais c'est
les deux gamines qui est au milieu qui
sont jade et joy un jour là on l a
entendu parler d'une butte d'une parce
qu'elle allait elle a fait un tweet dont
on a dit c'est grave et réelle certitude
la maman ça fait même pas un an un jour
leur mère c'est la pierre garcin jours
c'est leur frère et leurs sens en émoi
la maman la maman les exposé énormément
c'est quand même assez terrible enfin
moi aujourd'hui je perds violent parce
que vous êtes lamentables appartiennent
en fait une arme très exposée dans la
presse par le corps elles sont 13 ans
laissant beaucoup
voilà un moment donné on commence tous
aussi un petit peu penser à ces gamines
et se dire on va peut-être en parler un
petit peu moins et les laisser faire les
ententes en plantant de son protégé
elle voit rien à tout le monde en même
temps est-ce que emile est ce qu'on peut
entendre aussi que johnny a parlé de
savidan long en large en travers à aimer
partager avec le public et donc
peut-être que voilà c'est donc presque
dans une sorte de logique mais sert
sérénité moi je suis cucul la praline
j'aurais préféré que cette histoire ne
sortent jamais congrès moi je suis
absolument d'accord c'est à dire qu'à la
fin on est complètement gênés par ce
tout de ce débat là et en même temps on
se dit mais c'est pas possible qu'on
apprenne encore des trucs mais c'est pas
possible qu'on apprenne cette histoire
des sms mais c'est pas possible que
qu'on apprenne que et que bernard nous
nous confirme et que bernard de dawn ans
quand quinze jours
il saute son livre mais c'est vrai quand
on est à la fois gêné on et voyeur
reprendre veut savoir
on est un peu en otage en testant de
talent même temps gianni c'était notre
idole enfin moi je sais je parle en mon
nom mais tony moi j'étais totalement fan
de 16 hommes je vais musique toujours et
toujours bien sûr mais effectivement on
ne pense plus vraiment à l'artiste on
pense à toutes ces histoires tous ces
rebondissements nicolas qu'est ce qu'on
voit ce que je vois c'est étonnant c'est
les montants avancés par ce que 100
millions c'est impossible pour plein de
raisons
quelles raisons d'abord parce qu'il est
interprète alors même s'il avait un
excellent contrat à l'époque avec
universal il n'a pas pu engranger 100
millions que c'est quelqu'un qui ouvrait
ses dates quasiment deux ans deux ans et
demi à l'avance justement pour faire
rentrer de l'argent parce qu'il avait un
train de vie assez assez important donc
je pense que le prochain step donc l'art
vraisemblablement c'est pour essayer de
faire grossir un peu le truc mais je
pense qu'on est très très loin des 100
millions et puis on dit effectivement
que même si elle a même à 6 l à 100
millions d'euros en parlant d'être ici à
l'idée de patrimoine elle a trop de
dette trop de charges trop de maisons
avec trop d'employés il n'y a pas assez
de revenus
il va falloir nettoyer tout ça est ce
que vous confirmez
bernard sur ses maisons ses employés
c'est ce train de vie extraordinaire de
johnny on sait il l'avait souvent dit
d'ailleurs qu'il vivait au dessus de ses
moyens il vit d'ailleurs jean-claude
camus le disais il vit comme une rock
star hollywoodienne américaine avec un
âne train de vie et son ordinaire non
moi j'ai beau j'ai connu les maisons
celle de saint barth et extraordinaire
magnifique avec effectivement plein
employés afin qu'ils y sont pas y'a
personne non plus puisqu'il l'a loué
cette maison elle est louée donc ça
rapporte aussi des démêlés loup
tricheurs je crois qu'elle est louée
45000 le week end à 1000 euros le
week-end ils appuieraient la photo des
palissades qui est un très joli quartier
avec une piscine qui donne avec la forêt
est très jolie il a je crois qu'il ya
trois quatre personnes qui sont là
l'année ça coûte cher tout ça c'est sûr
olemps juste un dernier mot est ce que
vous pensez qu'on va avoir la dent les
dans les quelques jours parce qu'il y
avait une décision qui doit être rendue
un point final où est ce que ce n'est
que 1 pas point virgule
non je pense que l'a6 l'a10 il si le
tribunal de paris décident de geler les
droits artistiques
ça va encore aller un peu plus dans le
sens au moins deux on va dire de
conserver un petit peu tout cela avant
de finalement partager ou pas on verra
ce que dira la loi au final mais il est
possible quand même que les que les
partis et les avocats arrivent quand
même à discuter ensemble alors les
salaires et au final évidemment on
l'espère ce qu'on a tous le monde dans
laquelle on a vraiment vu qu'ils se
mettent à table et qu'ils se
réconcilient parce que c'était
évidemment la famille de johnny de celui
qu'on aimait